форма потрібного розміру для 23 річкової
анастасія в армії не знаєш лося
про дні підбирав і волонтери ж у зоні
ато про формулу дівчаток спочатку бітної до
міліції хоча б вона була стрільцем після
улама ми стоячи на на блокпостах
а крим пафф є та там писала захищала
б на такий у нас перевірка паспортного
режиму та маяки кущам сторонніх у
залийте хувс чи даєте залийте їх з
програм такі історики та вода
завданнями і виконали законно
дозволяю українським зинка мото
людську професію the muppets
запасом ейла знаєте обидва кухар часто
хваляться зинкою виткової служби всі
бойових спеціальностей були такі цуценята та
київради протяг її гранатометник
вона приклад опису до бухалтерки або
медики а за писання до начальниці бані
кайлас якогось вона з нір і оформляти
в армії на всіх каже в українській
чоловіків вітчиму фонді співаючи сотні досвідчених
ним щеня весь кових офісі але проти
ростова новий 617 їх у рази час на не
дасте автору до стеження запаси праці
виду я хоча б право нам зазвичай допомогу
я хочу документі слухаючи чи вручена
кубані до ось ці з брата через
voluntary професії на людські ж ночі
міністерство оборони розділило у 2014
уроки мовляв нібито влаштованих сил про
позначала щеня на бойові посади з
порушила б конституцію статті 24
конституції ви спочатку ще за рукава
ним фізіологічні особливості організм
чоловіки трудова законодавства маячить до
регламенту вати та nike
видай рубає звучать самотній немає але на
приватний можна щеня про означають вона
посади і кіпр відзначають вашому фізичному
братію а ось дівок вона не обидва з Києва
по трибуні
зовнішні години обидва стародавні підземні роботи
на сюди на Анастасія отримала статус
учасника бойових дій може працювати в
спати роті його дочка на подала заявку не
дівчата до неба рудь однак зміню в цю
роботу дівчина не планую я і
думаючи про стукіт на контрактну службу